nice to have you here brought the hot
stuff bag
oh okay let's let's not let's ramp up to
that gradually all right
we'll do this do it gently bentley yeah
okay we're off and running already
now i don't want to waste any time sue a
lot of people uh like myself
we don't talk about sex often this is a
chance for us to learn i was told that
the first thing you want to do is dispel
some common myths is that true well so
many people have such
bad idea wrong ideas about human
sexuality
uh men are convinced that to be a good
lover they've got to have this
humongous penis with an erection that is
so
rigid you can strike matches on it
[Applause]
so i'm lucky i make a lot of money
[Music]
[Applause]
aren't you glad you stuck around ray uh
you might know yeah um i haven't any
uh with women that you've never met
that's what you were just saying a while
ago and i thought oh that's interesting
okay so sue what you're saying
what you're saying then to us is that uh
that the
that's that's not true size does not
matter bigger is not better
penis size does not matter because you
know that
87 of females reach orgasm
by clitoral stimulation okay
now the clitoris is up here and the
vagina is appearing i'll take your word
for it
yeah please we're not going to have to
join you
i have no idea oh yeah right well
you'd be shocked uh so but where did
that myth come from then why do men
think that the penis has to be you know
as
uh huge as well they think that that
really is what women want
right that it's satisfying no we are
always delighted
when a guy comes into the bedroom with
this humongous erection
but it's from a psychological point of
view we look at that
penis and we say boy am i good
am i good i
really know how to turn him on
that noise at the end really bothered me
okay you are in a while since you've
heard it
[Applause]
if you're listening to my interview with
ray you'd know i
have a five-month-old uh that's what i'm
saying yeah okay let's move on
uh in a while orgasms are
you say orgasms are overrated grossly
overrated
the whole idea that females are going to
have this cataclysmic
earth-shattering ten on the richter
scale
orgasm every time they have sex uh-uh
not gonna happen hey yes it will
[Applause]
[Laughter]
ray's taking notes over here you are a
big proponent of sex toys yes but i want
to ask you something there are a lot of
people out there and i won't name names
but there are people that
they don't want to go and buy a sex toy
they're known they're on tv every night
and so they they're like you know they
they can't do that and and and then they
and they don't and it's a lot you know
they don't want to order it that seems
to what do you what do you suggest to
those people
well i think the last time i was here i
used the chin dong and i left it for you
uh yeah that was that was jay leno yeah
nasty
come here you little vic than you come
in
uh well you know but the thing is you
can
if you look around the house you can
always find things
that you can use as a sex toy what the
hell are you talking about
[Applause]
use something around the house yes like
what
absolutely an electric toothbrush
oh now wait a minute have you ever taken
an electric toothbrush and turned it
around oh turn it around
yeah yeah so that you're not using the
bristles yeah okay we don't have to
like yeah that's not a good image yeah
no no no no no
who's been using my toothbrush
[Applause]
you can't handle this the eggs it's
right up there and you at home no excuse
you can turn off right now if you want
to
why exactly you're talking about like a
desperate need of a vibra
a substitute for a vibrator yeah yeah
cause i've in not when i
marry but in my single days yes i've
been in a hotel and
the woman this is so personal
you're doing well the woman forgot hers
and
and and and it was a woman who needed it
and so i was desperate to find something
i went down to the gift shop and all i
could find was the monkey with the
symbols that did this
a little imagination here i would take
the symbols
off yeah you know i'd take those off but
then you've got
two free hands
uh-huh i see i want you to think of the
fun you could have with that
and and again it's a whole new meaning
to clackers but let's just to
to re research to rewind again clitoris
on top
right okay can you draw that for us
before you go
i would yes absolutely so but you are
there so there are there are
it's just like everyday items and you
can you and you've said told people you
can build your own how would you build
your own
bubble wrap
bubble wrap the man should wrap his
nose no no put bubble wrap on your flat
of your hand
duct tape it so it doesn't slide off
put some lube on it and you use it for
[Applause]
masturbation
who are you uh all right
we uh we're completely out of time uh
you you have
can you just show uh show us quickly one
of your devices you only have time for
one
oh i've got two of them i never leave
home without them
yeah yeah now look at that what is this
called this one
is the royal butler feel it feel it come
on i don't know
come on and you use this
you can stick it on the wall of the
shower what
what oh yeah i use this in the bathroom
yeah yeah please tell me for hanging a
towel or something
if push comes to shove you can use it
for hanging a towel
i trust you you guys are just yeah
i'm chicken sorry
it comes in other colors though yeah you
don't need red right red
something is wrong about it you put it
on the top speed i want to see if you
can make a milkshake with this thing
look at that it's moving it's oh yeah
yeah yeah it'll walk across the floor
come and get me big boy
all right uh all right we have another
one no no that's okay
uh we gotta go uh what is that
that's a happy rabbit okay this is where
this segment ends right here
uh we got to go i don't even want to
know what that does oh yes you
do no i don't look this thing is killing
itself it's jumping off the edge
it can't compete with that guy all right
well talk sex with sue johansen
airs sunday nights at 11 on oxygen sue
johansen thank you so much for being
[Applause]
here